it is okay to go against the grain again
it's like if you don't want to go to
college if you want to focus on you know
building a career if you want to have a
non-traditional like education even with
your family i don't have and it's
interesting being in the conservative
world i don't have like a very
traditional healthy nuclear family which
is something that people talk about a
lot and i kind of sit there and i'm like
yeah well somehow i made it out without
that very traditional but it's like i am
very much i don't believe that blood is
you know thicker than water in a lot of
ways i do think that you choose your own
family um i think you have to take
accountability for the people in your
life and what is serving you and you
have to figure out where to set those
boundaries and if that means walking
away from something that is traditional
that society is telling you oh you need
to focus on this it's okay to take
account for what is making you a better
person what is making you productive and
if you know things in your life are
holding you back figure out how to
readjust and move away from that and
find something that's healthier